are you looking to play fallout for this  weekend version 1.4 will be waiting for  you the patch already hit PC but the  tweaks and additions are now making  their way to ps4 and xbox one radroaches  aren't the only bugs getting squashed  first and foremost patch 1.4 adds  support for DLC as the Fez de will be  rolling out the first ad on very soon it  also adds new super mutant and Raider  items to the workshop and of course  there are plenty of bug fixes in place  more than two dozen in fact we've got  the full list of fixes up on gamespot  fallout 4 is first expansion ultimate  Ron is coming to the game this month  though Bethesda hasn't announced a  release date yet but considering this  update is setting the game up for  add-ons we should be seeing the new  content very soon in the meantime stick  with gamespot for all the fallout news  you need i'm tony you can find me on  twitter at chain-gun Pope and I can't  wait to get back to the Commonwealth